vingt ans après la musique à marguerite
duras écrit et met en scène musique
heures de au théâtre du rond point avec
sami frey et miou-miou vous allez
écouter et voir à l'instant marguerite
duras interviewé par marie claire
gauthier
seuls des choses qu'on traîne avec soin
très souvent tous les écrivains est rare
qu'on arrive à les faire
ce deuxième acte je vous dis que ça fait
20 ans que j'y pense mais j'ai fini
quand même par les clients et pourtant
un ordre dans l'écriture dans votre
écriture qui n'est jamais le même
finalement c'est j'espère je veux dire
le roman le film le théâtre ou alors
quelques fois le théâtre au cinéma le
rendement world cinéma tout seul vrai et
il n'y a jamais eu l'ordre exactement
alors là dedans arrive bon ce deuxième
acte ce deuxième musica et puis
également la mise en scène
qu'est ce que c'est la mise en scène
c'était un point d'orgue de la mise en
vente et ratures et autant la nuit dans
autant de le texte dans la musique à que
que en dehors de la musique à votre
corde quand par exemple je donne des des
indications comédiens toute cette partie
n'est pas là ce n'est pas retenue dans
l'écrit mais il existe un vivre l'église
28 dans le roman est exempt et n'existe
pas à moi de parler du roman qu'on est
en train de faire dans le tueur est là
pour préserver par exemple quatre
répliques
je peux parler une demi-heure aurait
justifié
je peux parler autour d'elle sans vous
donner des indications très très
précises dans les pièces que vous
écrivez pour la mise en scène et on voit
on voit vraiment déjà évoluer le
personnage qui fait comment ils comment
il réagit comment il se retourne et c
est ça vous pensé à ce moment là à vous
c'était dire un mise en scène que vous
pourrez faire vous vous pensez à une
mise en scène ou pour affaire de votre
pièce
je pense qu'à moi je crois
il ya que moi qui met en scène mes fils
quand ça arrive à d'autres
des erreurs qui font
m
la musique a étè plus jusqu'ici une
situation une pièce de personnages
c'est une situation un état de l'amour
qui décrit
un amour qui se défait alors qu'il
existe toujours que ce qui apparemment
se défait une situation banale avec le
deuxième acte il me semble que jaime
ruiz que vous appelez des personnages
sur des gens avec certains traits de
caractère qu'est ce que ça vous procure
ce théâtre cette mise en scène c'est un
jeu pour vous elle m'intéresse c'est
trop long pour le théâtre c'est
intéressant quand même ça me force à
travailler en profondeur
je voulais le travail de creusement
d'arrachement que l'on fait quand on
fait des textes de livres des textes qui
ne sont pas à parler et je connais ça se
travaille là pendant la mise en scène et
papa pendant l'écriture du texte et
culture du texte avant d'en parler ça
procède aussi d'un escamotage de quelque
chose du tout l'entourent de l'écrit
voyez quand vous l'entendez c'est
toujours bien on n' ont pas toujours de
dire si bien c'est bien pour vous c'est
vous dis que c'est bien quelques fois
j'y suis très contente et quelquefois je
jette tout général je recommence tout
dès que je mets en scène
c'est plus du tout la même musique a
qu'à quatre semaines que je répète
maintenant c'est une autre mais je pense
que cela est quand même à trois semaines
de jouer je pense que celle là va rester
mais si on me laissait pas moi c'est sûr
qu'elle touche pas tous encore ce que
vous éprouvez souvent cette sensation
que l'histoire n'est jamais fini
toujours de la vue